so I would imagine one of the challenges
of something like this is you're
obviously this is not some Marvel sized
budget yeah you have a finite budget to
tell your story and you're doing a
period piece talk about the challenges
of bringing that to life it was so hard
I'm not gonna lie you know 1978 New York
is not around anymore it's not what New
York does not look the same anymore and
we shot most of this movie on the
streets of New York we had one week on a
soundstage but everything else was on
location so that meant we had to work
really hard to get everything looking
right we had our production designer
Shane Valentino did an incredible job as
did our costume designer Sara Edwards
you know so people had to look right the
sets had to look right amazing period
cars and then there's probably 50% of
the movie has CGI in it I know as we
built buildings took buildings away you
wouldn't know it seeing the movie but
there we had a significant VFX budget
I'm fascinated by the editing process
because it's ultimately the final
rewrite I'm very curious you get in the
editing room you have all your footage
what's the thing that made you so happy
and what was the thing that frightened
you that's a great question what made me
happy was the woman's performances
because I knew right away that I had
killer performances out of all three of
them and that when in doubt go back to
the women when in doubt go you know we
Christopher tell us and the editor and I
kept saying when in doubt go to the
3-shot meaning when in doubt use a shot
of all three women together because we
knew that their cameras rather than
singles on the women because we knew
that their chemistry was so exceptional
that that you know if we were lost in
the scene the best thing was probably to
have a shot with all three of them so
that was the stuff I was most excited
about and then you know I think what I
was most daunted by was how much visual
effects work I knew needed to happen
that you know we would look at a scene
and think that we cannot get away with
that that's just it doesn't work it's 20
you see 20 18 to queerly and how much
work we had to ado to authentically
achieve 1978 that was daunting I always
ask people how long was your first cut
compared to the finished film not I
would say it was about 10 minutes longer
oh well yeah so that's really tight it's
always been it was always under two
hours
it was never over two hours even the
first cut okay now the test screening
process you go in there I know your
hearts freaking out
did you what did you learn in the test
screening process and how did that
impact the finished film that's a really
a question the test screening process is
atrocious but on the other hand the
audience tells you what they see right
so they're they're not pulling any
punches so if they're if it's not
working and it's not working it's not
like you can get up and say no no wait
let me explain the movie has to stand on
its own and audiences will tell you if
it works or not so for me it was really
about making sure that all of the plot
points were clear that we were telling a
clear story that nobody was confused by
anything and so that was that was the
feedback that there may have been a
couple of things that needed some
tightening in order for people to quit
understand some of the big twists
because we have some big twists at the
end so you want to set though make sure
those are being set up properly
completely I'm curious when you you're
going in on day one or before filming
begins what are you most nervous to pull
off with the budget and time that you
have besides like the making it a period
thing I wanted to make sure that no
matter what that we were focused and
moving quickly because we had an
incredibly difficult tight schedule only
at 38 days to shoot the movie which is
not enough for a movie this size so I
did a lot of work in prepping ahead of
time to make sure okay we're going to
get into this location and what is the
absolute essential thing we have to get
and we're gonna get that first because
if we run out of time I don't I'm not
gonna have time for my very pretty shots
but I have to make sure I'm
communicating what the story is at this
moment so I was really focused on going
through every scene and saying what is
the essential moment in this scene and
then getting that first